who is a survivor they're all survivors
we're about to look at the worst medical
injuries and emergencies that went down
on the show survivor got to give a huge
thank you to butcherbox for sponsoring
this video stay tuned to find out how
you can get two free filet mignons and
15 off your first box
i'm a little dizzy
what's happening
first bit of movement from lauren just a
slight adjustment what's happening
trying to keep from going numb probably
she's about to pass out see anything
i'm about to black out
whoa
oh
my god medical why'd he wait to run over
she announced it oh my god
what happened lauren passed out just
keep going just keep going she's got
people around her vic she's okay
yeah so this is probably a vasovagal
reaction where not enough circulation is
going to her brain she's probably going
to come too real quick you just fainted
yep damn it
i didn't get the golden buzzer or
whatever they have on this show
community idol
yesterday a piece of sand got in my eye
and i guess i scratch my eye oh corneal
abrasion is so painful the cornea has
some of the most nerve fibers in the
entire human body like concentration
wise tearing visual difficulties pain
pain pain pain it got swollen and i
couldn't sleep at night oh that's an
infection my man needs antibiotics the
first thing i'm gonna do is try and have
a look inside your eye so the way that
we do this in order to do an exam for a
corneal abrasion is we put a fluorescent
stain we put it's like a little thing on
the edge of the eye it puts a stain and
you just have to be really careful
because it could permanently stay in
contact and close and then we either use
a woods lamp to light up the eye a pen
with a blue filter or a proper way to do
it as a slit lamp exam you can see if
there's any corneal abrasions there
based on where the deposits of the
fluorescent stain go what i need to rule
out is that he hasn't got an abrasion or
an abnormality on his cornea which is
the clear part that covers his eye so
the only way to do that is to put in an
orange dye and i'm able to see things
more clearly okay okay so that's a
fluorescent strip basically when you put
at the edge of the eye it makes the eye
really orangey and yellow it actually
looks like there is what i would call a
divot in this corner oh that's a problem
is there something we can do out here no
unfortunately not antibiotics
anti-inflammatories
oh what happened oh my god
he's burnt he's burnt
[Music]
he fell into
there must have been some toxic fumes
there because smoke inhalation for a
short period of time is rarely strong
enough to cause you to pass out
instantly the only way that can happen
is there's some kind of chemical process
going on like something burning causing
a poison sensation when you're in around
a fire there's a few things that can
happen that could cause you to not get
enough oxygen a fire essentially burns
and eats up off that oxygen so it can
cause you to asphyxiate also when you're
burning something you naturally create
carbon monoxide which when you inhale
actually binds with the hemoglobin in
your blood which normally carries oxygen
and competes with the oxygen that you're
also inhaling to bind to that hemoglobin
forming carboxy hemoglobin and then that
circulates through your body not giving
your tissues the oxygen that it needs
and as a result you can die from carbon
monoxide poisoning we've seen that time
and time again and the way to reverse
that is by giving a patient a ton of
oxygen to sort of out-compete
that carbon monoxide that is already
floating around in the blood trying to
bind to the hemoglobin another thing
obviously that can happen is like a
chemical burn of your trachea and that's
really problematic you need a breathing
tube for that
i can't decide whether i should keep
trying to send them or not okay so
burning of the hands is is a very big
problem i mean obviously a lot of nerve
fibers on your fingers and hands in
order for you to feel the world around
you as a result that means it's going to
hurt a ton more and then on top of it
because of the way burns heal on this
area specifically you form contractures
so you're usually going to need multiple
surgeries or procedures to keep those
contractures from forming i'll take
whatever you give me i'll take the pain
i'll do whatever you guys say breathe
when you breathe look that's the pen
that's the pen we saw in uh bondi beach
how did they do this before we had pain
control that's all i think about
i'm actually worried
i'm not sure but i think i got a bug in
my ear oh that's why we have earwax but
instead of crawling out it is getting
deeper in my ear well it's not getting
deeper like there's there's no real
place for it to go it's not gonna crawl
into your eustachian tube i can't sleep
i can't get comfortable
it's just disgusting hearing these
little legs crawl around in your head
oh
what is that little thingy it's like a
little worm it's like a miniature
salmonella salmonella salomon
back to the show in just a second but
first i want to talk to you about
butcher box one of the hardest parts of
trying to survive on a deserted island
would be the drastic change in your diet
but thanks to butcher box i have no
trouble getting my hands on fresh high
quality meat and fish as some of you
know this last year i've completely
transformed my diet ahead of my boxing
debut undefeated by the way which means
i got to enjoy a ton of butcher box free
range usda certified organic chicken and
wild cod seafood butcher box delivers
incredible meat and fish directly to my
door thanks to them i can trust the high
quality meat and fish i put on my table
each day it's better for me the farmers
the animals welfare and ultimately our
planet in particular i've been enjoying
their wild alaskan sockeye salmon which
is fresh and flavorful while also being
packed full of nutrients one of the best
parts is you can choose your box and
delivery frequency so you get exactly
the foods you and your family love all
in an eco-friendly 100 recyclable box
and if you sign up right now butcher box
is gonna give you two free filet mignons
and fifteen dollars off your first box
not to mention that shipping is always
free all right let's get back to the
show beauty pulls it out second place
finished reward for beauty nothing for
brawn
but an empty lonely afternoon back at
camp they look hot and dry and i point
out dry specifically because if you're
in a hot environment and you're not
sweating that tells me that you're
potentially susceptible to heat stroke
caleb water
did we just predict a little something
okay so heat stroke is really dangerous
especially in environments like this
because you lose the ability to cool off
see your natural temperature set by your
brain a part of your brain called the
hypothalamus and it usually sets your
temperature to around 98 degrees
fahrenheit 98.6 is the typical norm that
we use but it does fluctuate a degree or
two when you're in this position your
temperature starts going up and not
because of your hypothalamus and you
lose the ability to cool yourself likely
because you're dehydrated likely because
you've tried to sweat and it's been
inefficient so as a result your organs
can start failing your brain can stop
functioning you can go into a coma like
heat stroke is one of the deadliest
parts of being outdoors and usually it's
accentuated by activity so strenuous
activity like being on the show survivor
all right dude we got some water coming
hang in there all right the first thing
you'd want to do is obviously give water
with water you're able to sweat and when
you're sweating you can evaporate that
liquid and then as a result cool your
body off because remember when
evaporation occurs the surface of the
skin does cool down anybody back out
which is what they're doing buddy you're
in really good hands i want someone to
do some vitals on him like check his
vitals i need to know what his pulse is
what his blood pressure is i need to
know if he's neurologically intact
so joe you're giving him fluids to
rehydrate and what we're gonna give
caleb some cold intravenous fluids try
and bring his temperature down fluids
internally that are cold will actually
speed up the cooling process now
something we do with patients whenever
we cool them down with a solution like
that or spraying them with cold water
the body's natural reaction sometimes
it's a shiver which increases the
temperature and that this is not a time
you want that to happen so we would
actually give a patient the muscle
relaxer like a benzodiazepine to help
calm them down to decrease that shiver
response in order to allow us to cool
them down
caleb you know there's only two ways you
leave this game other than being voted
out and that's quitting which you
clearly are not doing and that is a
doctor saying they are too worried about
you to let you continue
you don't want to be pulled buddy you
don't have a choice yeah
it's a doctor's call yeah you don't want
to mess around with this because
permanent brain damage is not something
you want to be a contestant on the
survivor okay
yeah mountain st neil actually blew its
lid this afternoon huge chunk of pus
came out and then there's something even
grosser on my back
okay that doesn't look good it looks
like some kind of animal bite there's
some kind of necrosis happening there
the black tissue i mean i'm looking to
see that you know what what it could
potentially become
and that one is in the skin but there's
nothing under there i think will
immediately be damaged
so assessment on this is what um it's a
big abs nasty spot he said it's a big
nasty spot is that is this big nasty
spot a medical diagnosis these days yeah
i don't know what that is and it's
definitely not life-threatening in the
moment but like in the jungle i would
love to know what could have caused it
like this person obviously knows way
more than me and being close to a joint
like the knee is that
more serious correct having the an
infection near the knee puts you at a
higher risk for septic arthritis which
is an infection of the joint or
osteomyelitis which is an infection of
the bone both of those are quite serious
and require iv antibiotics is his wound
that bad the front one doesn't look
terrible it just looks like there's some
tissue there that's forming to uh create
sort of the next layer of healing what
you want to look for is the tissue
surrounding it like is the redness
starting to spread is there streaking
happening some fluctuance below the
wound basically signs of the cellulitis
is what you're looking for i didn't see
that on that initial look
migraine
nightmare
back pain from sleeping on the floor
[Applause]
bruce had really horrible stomach pains
he's had pains for about four days now
and it just got
really unbearable for him the worry here
is appendicitis obviously that's a
surgical emergency colitis would be a
big problem too you're going to need
antibiotics for that and i'm going to
assist you first before i can uh
give you any treatment that's really
important with abdominal pain that you
don't give
pain medicine too early in the treatment
before you examine because you might not
know what's going on don't don't
the areas where he's pushing looks like
it's an appendicitis technically
appendicitis starts on the right lower
quadrant but there's been stories of
patients having it in the center of
their abdomen then migrating to the
right lower quadrant some people having
contralateral pain on the opposite side
so like there's never a clear answer
with appendicitis especially it depends
on where in the course of the
appendicitis that you are early stages
late stages has it perforated now is
spreading throughout your entire abdomen
i can't rule out those appendix sure
points
[Music]
getting transported like that with a
appendicitis would be so painful because
any kind of jiggling of the abdomen of
an acute abdomen is so painful that's
why one of the special tests we use is
we have a patient jump on their heels to
see if there is a truly acute abdomen
they'll tell you right away they'll
scream and tell you that's terrible they
ran some tests and found out that his
entire digestive system his colon and
his bladder were blocked nothing was
coming out what are they saying he was
constipated something doesn't make sense
he had such bad constipation that it was
also blocking his bladder
because the colon runs from here across
up and then down and then becomes the
small intestine the bladder is down here
in the pubic area the only thing that it
could be a vesiculo
vesiculocolonic
fistula where if you have a passageway
in between created between the colon and
the bladder where feces can actually
travel into the bladder causing an
infection and a blockage i can't feel my
hands
why can't she feel her hands all right
you're all right you're right i'm right
here with you
you doing all right i can't tell if i'm
panicking or dehydrating hey medical dr
joe dr joe dr mike we're all first name
here
my arms are cramping up that's because
you're breathing a little bit quickly
all right what's wrong with hannah i
don't know
you're not gonna let me die
you're gonna let me die i love that he's
god and he controls who lives and dies
this is just because you're breathing a
little bit quick so if you breathe out
too quickly you can actually create an
oxygen carbon dioxide imbalance like
sort of over blow off carbon dioxide and
as a result cause a acid base imbalance
in your bloodstream i knew coming out
here that panic attacks are something
that i'm prone to but i just didn't want
to be one of those people well panic
attacks can make the situation worse
because during a panic attack you feel
tightness of the chest you start getting
anxious when you're hyperventilating you
release too much carbon dioxide when you
release carbon dioxide which acts as an
acid in your blood you actually shift
that to have your blood become a higher
ph which makes it more basic that's why
people say breathe into a bag because
then you re-inhale some of that carbon
dioxide oh really that's where the bad
thing is yeah
here's a list of 10 foods that can
actually kill you click here to check
that out and remember if you sign up to
butcher box right now you're going to
get two free filet mignons and 15 off
your first box as always stay happy and
healthy